start by fine lardons in a large pan  these smug chunks of bacon have a  delicious deep salty flavor that makes  them perfect with pasta when the lard  will start to brown add finely chopped  garlic and turn off the heat next add  farfalle to boiling salted water named  after the italian for butterflies this  boat I'd say pasta has a large service  area great for sticking to sources just  before the pasta is ready add frozen  peas to the boiling pasta water  then when the pasta and the peas are  cooked drain and add to the lardons and  the garlic  spooning creme fraiche  and dot with lumps of creamy ricotta  cheese  season then serve ready in just 12  minutes  fart fairy with ricotta and Jetta and  peas a delicious quick and easy supper  that's ready when you are finish that  with a nice ball of creme fraiche let  that sit there beef is so soft it's  almost like slicing through butter the  knife do the work